we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 David P here is a caller
I this is one the guy who calls in his
connection is always very strange it
sounds like a 1930s phone connection
it's very interesting he very strongly
and powerfully denounces paywalls and
reminds me to remind you
we produce the show and you can watch it
for free this is a good guy
David I know you got a lot going on in
your in your show yes you've got a lot
of stuff to get through and limited time
and maybe that's part of the reason why
you slipped up this time and you forgot
to mention when you ask people to
subscribe remind them this is not
something they have to pull up put a
pull a credit card out correct they can
go on on their computer and subscribe
and not worry about having a paywall
it's free you forgot to mention that
so I'm reminding you a suggestion maybe
put a sticky notepad
below the monitor or whatever you look
at the camera so that you can read it
and and you can be reminded you can
remind yourself to mention subscriptions
there are no charge that's exactly right
and of course this gentleman is talking
about podcast and YouTube folks we're
giving it away we're giving it away the
entire YouTube show is free you
subscribe free on YouTube the audio
podcast is free now the way we pay for
that is there's advertising and if you
want to get rid of the advertising you
get a membership on my website speaking
of the membership the membership gets
you the bonus show on today's bonus show
we will talk about the FCC commissioner
calling for a tick tock ban
wow we will talk about how predatory
gambling has helped the lottery Reach
This sky-high jackpot that so many
people have written to me about and we
have polling from Pennsylvania which
finds seven percent of Pennsylvania
voters have been dissuaded from voting
for John fetterman because of his stroke
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com